الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول الله حي على الصلاه حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح حي على الفلاح قد
قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا سووا الصف سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
فمن اظلم ممن كذب على الله او كذب بالصدق
اذ
جاءه وكذب بالصدق اذ
جاءه اليس في
جهنم مثوا
للكافرين والذي جاء بالصدق وصدق به
اولئك هم
المتقون
والذي والذي جاء بالصدق وصدق به اولئك هم
المتقون لهم
يشاءون عند
ربهم ذلك
جزاء
المحسنين ليكفر الله عنهم اسوا الذي عملوه
ويجزيهم اجرهم باحسن الذي كانوا
يعملون اليس الله بكاف
عبده
ويخونك بالذين من دونه ومن يضلل الله فما
له من هاد ومن يهدي الله فما له من
مضل
اليس الله
بعزيز ذذ
انتقام ولئن
سالتهم من خلق السماوات والارض
ليقولن
الله
ليقولن الله قل
افرايتم ما تدعون من دون
الله قل افراي
ما تدعون من دون الله ان ارادني الله
بضر ان ارادني الله بضر هل هن كاشفات ضره
او ارادني او ارادني او ارادني او ارادني
برحمه هل
هنكات
رحمتي قل حسبي
الله قل حسبي الله عليه
يتوكل
المتوكلون قل يا قوم عملوا على مكانتكم
اني
عامل ياتيه عذاب يخزي ويحل عليه عذاب مقيم
انا انزلنا عليك الكتاب ل
بالحق فمن اهتدى فلنفسه ومن ضل
فانما يضل
عليها وما انت عليهم
بوكيل الله يتوفى
الانفس حين
موتها والتي لم تمت في
منامها فيمسك التي قضى عليه الموت ويرسل
الاخرى الى اجل
مسمى ان في ذلك لايات
لقوم
يفكرون ام اتخذوا من دون الله
شفعاء قل اولا يملكون
شيئا قل اولو قل اولو يملكون شيئا
ولا
يعقلون اولو كانوا يملكون
شيئ ولا
يعقلون قل لله الشفاعه
جميعا له ملك
السما الارض ثم اليه
ترجعون واذا ذكر الله وحده اشما ازت قلوب
الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره اذا ذكر الذين من
دونه
هم اذا هم
يستبشرون قل
اللهم فاطر السماوات والارض عالم الغيب
والشهاده انت
تح عبادك ما كانوا فيه
يختلفون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
سبحان
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل اللهم فاطر السماوات والارض عالم
الغيب
والشهاده انت تحكم بين عبادك فيما كانوا
فيه
يختلفون ولو ان للذين ظلموا ما في الارض
جميعا ومثل
مع ومثله معه لافتدوا به من سوء سء العذاب
يوم
القيامه وبدى لهم من الله ما لم يكونوا
يحتسبون وبدى لهم سيئات ما كسبوه وحاق لهم
وحق بهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون فاذا مس الانسان ضر
دعانا
ثم اذا خولناه نعمه
مما قال قال انما اوتيته على علم بل هي
فتنه
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون بل هي فتنه
يعلمون قد
قالين من قبلهم فما اغنى عنهم ما كانوا
يكسبون فاصابهم سيئات ما
كسبوه وللذين ظلموها وللذين ظلموا من
هؤلاء
سيصيبهم والذين ظلموا من
هؤلاء سيصيبهم س
ما
كسبوا وما
هم
بمعجزين اولم
يعلموا ان الله يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء
ويقدر
ان في ذلك
لايات
لقوم
يؤمنون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله الله
اك الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استفر
‏h
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا عبا دي الذين اسرفوا على
انفسهم لا تقنطوا من رحمه الله ان الله
يغفر الذنوب
جميعا انه هو الغفور الرحيم وانيبوا الى
ربكم واسلموا له من قب
انكم العذاب ثم لا تنصرون
واتبعوا احسن ما انزل اليكم من
ربكم من قبل ان ياتيكم العذاب
بغته وانتم لا
تشعرون ان تقول نفس يا حسره
على في جن الله وان كنت لمن الساخ
او تقول لو ان الله هداني لكنت من
المتقين او تقول حين ترى العذاب لو ان لي
كره لو ان لي كره فاكون من
المحسنين بل قد
جاءتك اياتي فكذبت بها واستك كبرت
واستكبرت وكنت من
الكافرين ويوم القيامه تر الذين كذبوا على
الله
وجوههم
مسوده اليس في جهنم مثوا
للمتكبرين وينج الله الذين اتقوا بمفازتهم
لا يمسهم
السوء لا يمسهم
السوء ولا هم
يحزنون الله خالق كل شيء وهو على كل شيء
وكيل
لهيد السماوات والارض والذين كفروا بايات
الله
اولئك هم
الخاسرون قل افغير الله
تامرون اعبد
الجاهلون ولقد اوحي اليك والى الذين من
قبلك لئن اشركت
ليحبطن عملك
ولتكونن من
الخاسرين بل الله فاعبد
بل الله فاعبد وكن من
الشاكرين وما قدر الله حق قدره والارض
جميعا قبضته يوم
القيامه والسماوات
مطويات
بيمينه سبحانه وتعالى
عما
يشركون ونفخ في الصور صعق من في السماوات
ومن في الارض
الا الا من
شاء
الله ثم نفخ فيه اخرى فاذا هم قيام
ينظرون واشرقت الارض بنور ربها ووضع
الكتاب ووضع الكتاب وج
بالنبيين
والشهداء وقضي
بينهم وقضي بينهم بالحق وهم لا
يظلمون ووفيت كل نفس ما عملت وهو اعلم بما
يفعلون وسيق الذين كفروا الى الى
جهنم
زمرا حتى اذا
جاؤوها فتحت ابوابها وقال لهم خزنه
خزنتها وقال لهم
خزنتها ياتكم رسل منكم يصون
عليكم الم ياتكم رسل منكم يقصون عليكم
ايات ر
وينذرونكم
وينذرونكم لقاء يومكم
هذا قالوا بلى ولكن حقت كلمه العذاب على
الكافرين قيل ادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين
فيها خالدين فيها فبئس فبئس خالدين فيها
فبئس مثوى
متكبرين وسيق الذين اتقوا ربهم الى
الجنه
سمرا حتى اذا
جاؤوها وفتحت ابوابها وقال لهم
خزنتها وقال لهم خزنتها سلام
عليكم طبتم فادخلوها
خالدين قالوا الحمد لله الذي صدقنا وعده
واورثنا الارض واورثنا الارض نتبوا من
الجنه حيث
نشاء فنعم اجر
العاملين وترى
الملائكه
حافين ر
حافين من حول العرش
يسبحون يسبحون بحمد ربهم وقض بينهم
بالحق وقيل الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله ا
اكبر الله اكبر بسم الله
ال الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
حاميم تنزيل الكتاب من الله العزيز
العليم غافر ال ب وقابل التوب شديد العقاب
ذي
الطول لا اله الا هو اليه
المصير ما يجادل في ايات الله الا الذين
كفروا فلا يغررك تقلبهم في
البلاد كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح والاحزاب من
بعدهم وهمت كل امه برسولهم
لياخذه وجادلوا بالباطل ليدحضوا به الحق
فاخذتهم فكيف كان
عقاب
وكذلك وكذلك حقت كلمه ربك على الذين كفروا
انهم اصحاب النار
الذين يحملون العرش ومن حوله يسبحون بحمد
ربهم يسبحون بحمد ربهم ويؤمنون به
ويستغفرون
ويستغفرون للذين امنوا
ربنا ربنا وسعت كل شيء رحمه
وعلما فاغفر ل الذين تابوا واتبعوا سبيلك
وقهم عذاب
الجحيم ربنا وادخلهم
جنات عدن التي
وعدتهم ومن صلح من
ابائهم وازواجهم
وذرياتهم انك انت العزيز
الحكيم وقهم
السيئات ومن تق السيئات
يومئذ فقد رحمته ذلك هو الفوز
العظيم ان الذين كفروا ينادون لمقت الله
اكبر من مقتكم
انفسكم اذ تدعون الى الايمان فتكفرون
قالوا ربنا امتنا اثنتين واحييتنا
اثنتين فاعترفنا بذنوبنا فهل الى خروج من
سبيل ذلكم
بانه اذا دعي الله وحده كفرتم
وان يشرك به تؤمنه فالحكم لله العلي
الكبير
هو الذي يريكم اياته
وينزل وينزل لكم من
السماء رزقا وما يتذكر الا من
ينيب فادعوا الله مخلصين له
الدين مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون رفيع الدرجات ذو العرش يلقي
الروح من امره يلقي الروح من امره على من
يشاء من
عباده لينذر يوم
التلاق يوم هم بارزون لا
يخفى منهم
ش لمن الملك
اليوم لمن الملك اليوم
لله
ال
ال اليوم تجزى كل نفس بما كسبت لا ظلم
اليوم ان الله سريع
الحساب
وانذرهم يوم
الازفه قلوب لدى الحناجر كاظمين
ما للظالمين من حم ولا شفيع
يطاع يعلم
خائنه الاعين وما تخفي
الصدور والله يقضي
بالحق والله يقضي
بالحق والذين يدعون من دونه لا يق
بشيء ان
الله ان الله هو السميع
البصير الله
اكبر سمع
الله
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام
عليكم
الله
[Silence]
استقيم ترص
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اولم يسيروا في الارض
فينظروا كيف كان عاقبه الذين كانوا من
قبلهم
م اشد منهم قوه
واثار في الارض فاخذهم الله بذنوبهم وما
كان لهم من الله من
واق ذلك بانهم كانت تاتيهم رسلهم بالبينات
فكفروا فاخذهم الله انه قوي شديد العقاب
ولقد ارسلنا موسى
باياتنا
وسلطان
مبين فرعون وهامان وقارون فقالوا ساحر
كذاب فلما
جاءهم بالحق من عندنا قالوا
اقتلوا الذين
امنوا واستحي
نساءهم وما ك الكافرين الا في
ضلال وقال فرعون ذروني اقتل موسى وليدع
ربه اني اخاف ان يبدل دينكم او ان يظ في
الارض
الفساد وقال موسى اني عذت بربي وربكم من
كل متكبر لا يؤمن بيوم
الحساب وقال رجل مؤمن من ال فرعون يكتم
ايمانه اتقتلون رجلا ان يقول ربي الله وقد
جا وقد
جاءكم بالبينات من ربكم وان يك كاذبا
فعليه كذبه وان يك صادقا يصبكم بعض الذي
يعدكم ان الله لا يهدي من هو مسرف
كذاب يا قوم لكم الملك اليوم ظاهرين في
الارض فمن ينصرنا من باس الله ان
جاءنا قال فرع فون ما اريكم الا ما ارى
وما اهديكم الا سبيل
الرشاد وقال الذي امن يا قوم اني اخاف
عليكم مثل يوم
الاحزاب مثل داب قوم نوح وعاد وثمود
والذين من بعدهم وما الله يريد ظلما
للعباد
ويا قوم اني اخاف عليكم يوم
التناد يوم تولون مدبرين ما لكم من الله
من عاصم ومن يضلل الله فما له من
هاد ولقد
جاء يوسف من قبل
بالبينات فما زلتم
في ما
جاءكم به حتى اذا هلك قلتم لن يبعث الله
من بعده
رسولا كذلك يضل الله من هو مسرف
مرتاب الذين يجادلون في ايات الله بغير
سلطان اتاهم كبر مقتا عند الله عند الذين
امنوا كذلك يطبع الله على كل قلب
متكبر
جبار الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين وقال فرعون يا هامان ابن لي صرحا
لعلي ابلغ
الاسباب اسباب السماوات فاطلع الى اله
موسى واني
لا
كاذبا وكذلك ين لفر عون سوء عمله وصد عن
السبيل وما
ك وما كيد فرعون الا في
تباب وقال الذي امن يا قوم اتبعون اهدكم
سبيل
الرشاد يا قوم انما هذه الحياه الدنيا
متاع وان الاخ خره هي دار
القرار من عمل سيئه فلا يجزى الا
مثلها ومن عمل صالحا من ذكر او انثى وهو
مؤمن
فاولئك
يدخلون
الجنه
فاولئك يدخلون الجنه يرزقون فيها بغير
حساب الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
السلام علكم
ورحمه ان شا الله امام
حسن
[Silence]
‏and you know often j iser
as just going out to
fight ‏however you know we have to be
mindful that there are other there are
other types of
jih jihad is not just about fighting
physically for a cause you fight
yourself mentally you fight your urges
you fight the things that
are you fight the things that you
attracted to that are not good for you
and you fight the things that will that
will
صل الله عليه
وسلم
things so those fight
ures
ان
قران بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والعصر ان
الانسان لفي
خصر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر
‏fight
[Silence]
ستق ان شاء
الله جهاد
النفس
‏many b fight you desires as
said low even you
[Silence]
have another
‏outs
isam other
things there small the small daily
choices that le
to living a living a life and your
‏keep under
things chic
make ‏choosing choosing the truth over
lies choosing patience over your
impulsivity and i know that every single
one of us in this room can choose our
pati over the impuls we are all
fasting we all fasting today i
hope choosing your forgiveness over the
resentment never hold a grge on
a never hold grge on a s there's no need
for that
ان شاء
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى ان شاء
الله ان شاء
الله
شاء وصل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وه
وصحبه
[Silence]
اجمعين استقيم
واستو
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهد المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ويا قوم لي ادعوكم الى النجاه
وتدعونني
النار تدعونني لاكفر بالله واشرك به ما
ليس لي به علم انا ادعوكم الى العزيز
الغفار لا جرم ان ما تدعونني اليه ليس له
دعوه في الدنيا ولا في الاخره وان مردنا
الى الله وان الين هم اصحاب
النار فستذكرون ما اقول لكم وفوض امري الى
الله ان الله بصير
بالعباد فوطه الله سيئات ما ذكروا وحاق
بال فرعون
سوء
العذاب النار يعرضون عليها غدوا
وعشيا ويوم تقوم الساعه اخلوا ال فرعون
اشد
العذاب واذ
يتحاجون في النار فيقول
ضعفاء للذين استكبروا انا كنا لكم تبعا
فهل انتم
مغنون فهل انتم مغنون عنا نصيبا من النار
قال الذ ذين استكبروا انا كل فيها ان الله
قد حكم بين
العباد وقال الذين النار لخزنه جهنم ادعوا
ربكم يخفف عنا يوما من
العذاب قالم تك تاتيكم رسلكم
بالبينات
ق قالوا وما
دعاء الكافرين الا في ضلال انا لننصر رسل
الين امنوا الحياه الدنيا ويوم يقوم
الاشهاد يوم لا ينفع الظالمين معذرتهم هم
اللعنه ولهم سوء
الدار ولقد اتينا موسى الهدى وثنا بني
اسرائيل الكتاب هدى وذكرى لاولي
الالباب فاصبر ان وعد الله حق وسبح
بحمده فاصبر على ما يقولون واستغفر لذنبك
وسبح بحمد ربك بالعشي والابكار
فاصبر ان وعد الله حق
واستغفر لذنبك وسبح بحمد ربك بالعشي
والابكار
ان الذين يجادلون في ايات الله بغير سلطان
اتاهم ان في صدورهم الا كبر ما هم
ببالغيه فاست بال الله انه هو السميع
البصير لخلق السماوات والارض اكبر من خلق
الناس ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون وما يستوي الاعمى والبصير والذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات ولا
المسيء قليلا ما
تتذكرون ان الساعه لاتيه لا ريب فيها ولكن
اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون وقال ربكم ادعوني استجب لكم ان
الذين يستكبرون عن عبادتي سيدخلون جهنم
داخلين الذي جعل لكم الليل لتسكنوا فيه
والنهار مبصرا ان الله لذو فضل على الناس
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يشكرون ذلكم الله ربكم خالق كل شيء لا اله
الا هو فانا
تؤفكون كذلك يؤفك الذين كانوا بايات الله
يجحدون الله الذي جعل لكم الارض قرارا
والسماء
بناء
وصوركم فاحسن صوركم ورزقكم من
الطيبات ذلكم الله ربكم فتبارك الله رب
العالمين هو الحي لا اله الا هو فادعوه
مخلصين له
الدين الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اني نهيت ان اعبد الذين ت عون من دون
الله لما
جاءني البينات من ربي وامرت لان اسلم لرب
العالمين هو الذي خلقكم من تراب ثم من
نطفه ثم من علقه ثم يخرجكم طفلا ثم
لتبلغوا اشدكم ثم لتكونوا شيوخا
ومنكم من
يتوفى قبل ولتب اجلا
مس ولعلكم
تعقلون هو الذي يحيي
ويميت فاذا قضى امرا فانما يقول له كن
فيكون الم تر الى الذين يجادلون في ايات
الله انا يصرفون
الذين كذبوا بالكتاب وبما ارسلنا به رسلنا
فسوف
ي
اذلال في اعناقهم
والسلاسل حبون في ثم في النار
يسجرون ثم قيل لهم اينما كنتم
تشركون من دون الله قالوا ضلوا عن نا بل
لم نكن ندعو من قبل
شيئا كذلك يضل الله
الكافرين ذلكم بما كنتم تفرحون في الارض
بغير الحق وبما كنتم
تمرحون ادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين فيها
فبئس مثوى
المتكبرين فاصبر ان وعد الله حق فاما
نرينك بعض الذي نعدهم او نتوفينك
فالينا
يرجعون ولقد ارسلنا رسلا من قبلك منهم من
قصصنا عليك ومنهم من لم نقصص عليك وما كان
لرسول ان ياتي بايه الا باذن
فاذا
جاء امر الله قضي بالحق وخسر هنالك
المبطلون الله الذي جعل لكم الانعام
تركبوا منها ومنها
تاكلون ولكم فيها منافع ولتبلغوا عليها
حاجه في
صدوركم وعليها وعلى الفلك تحملون
ويريكم اياته فاي ايات الله
تنكرون يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف كان
عاقبه الذين من قبلهم كانوا اكثر منهم
واشد قوه
واثا في الارض فما اغنى عنهم ما كانوا
يكسبون
جاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات فرحوا بما عنده من
العلم وحاق بهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون فلما راوا باسنا قالوا
امنا بالله وحده وكفرنا بما كنا به
مشركين فلم يك ينفع
ايمانهم لما راوا باسنا
سنه التي ق عباده زر هنالك
[Silence]
الكافرون سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم رب الع
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم ير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
امم
تنزيل من الرحمن
الرحيم كتاب فصلت اياته قرانا ع لقوم
يعلمون بشيرا ونذيرا فاعرض اكثرهم فهم لا
يسمعون وقالوا كنا في
اكنه من ما تدعونا اليه وفي اذاننا وقر
ومن بيننا وبينك
الب اعمل اننا
عاملون قل انما انا بشر مثلكم يوحى الي
انما الهكم اله واحد فاستقيموا اليه
واستغفروه وويل للمشركين
الذين لا يؤتون الزكاه هم بالاخره هم
كافرون ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لهم اجر غير
ممنون قل اكم لتكفرون بالذي خق الارض في
يومين وتجعلون له
اندادا ذلك
رب
وجعل فيها رواسي من فوقها وبارك فيها وقدر
فيها اقواتها في اربعه
ايام
سواء
للسائلين ثم استوى الى
السماء وهي دخان فقال لها وللارض ائتيا
طوعا او كرها قالت اتينا
طائعين فقضاهن سبع
سماوات في يومين واوحى في كل
سماء
امرها وزينا
السماء الدنيا بمصابيح
وحفظا ذلك تقدير العزيز
العليم فان اعرضوا فقل انذرتكم صاعقه مثل
صاعقه عاد
وثمود اذ
جاءتهم الرسل من بين ايديهم ومن خلفهم الا
تعبدوا الا الله قالوا لو شاء ربنا لانزل
ملائكه
فانا ارسلتم به
كافرون فاما عاد فاستكبروا في الارض بغير
الحق وقالوا من اشد منا قوه اولم يروا ان
الله الذي خلقهم هو اشد منهم قوه وكانوا
باياتنا
يجحدون فارسلنا عليهم ريحا صرصرا في ايام
نح لنذيقهم عذاب الخزي في الحياه الدنيا
ولعذاب الاخره اخزى وهم لا
ينصرون واما ثمود فهديناهم فاستحبوا العى
على الهدى فاخذتهم صاعقه العذاب الهون بما
كانوا
يكسبون ونجينا
الذين وكانوا
يتقون ويوم يحشر اعداء
الله الى النار فهم
يوزعون حتى اذا ما
جاؤوها شهد عليهم سمع ابصارهم
وجنودهم بما كانوا
يعملون وقالوا لجلودهم لم شهدتم
علينا قالوا انطقنا الله الذي انطق كل شيء
وهو خلقكم اول مره واليه
ترجعون وما كنتم تستترون ان يشهد عليكم
سمعكم ولا ابصاركم
ولا
ولكن ولكن ظننتم ان الله لا يعلم كثي مما
تعملون وذلكم
ظنكم ظننتم بربكم داكم فاصبحتم فاصبحتم من
الخاسرين فان يصبروا فالنار مثوى لهم وان
يستعتبوا فما هم من
متبين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قيضنا لهم
قرنا فزينوا لهم ما بين ايديهم وما خلفهم
حق عليهم القول في امم قد من قبلهم من
الجن والانس انهم كانوا
خاسرين وقال الذين كفروا لا اسمعوا لهذا
القران فيه لعلكم
تغلبون فذي قن الذين كفروا عذابا شديدا
ولنجزينهم اسوا الذي كانوا
يعملون ذلك
جزاء
اعداء الله النار لهم فيها دار الخلد
جزاء بما كانوا باياتنا
يجحدون وقال الذين كفروا ربنا ارنا الذين
اضلانا من الجن والانس نجعلهما تحت
اقدامنا ليكونا من
الاسفلين ان الذين قالوا ربنا الله ثم
استقاموا تتنزل عليهم
الملائكه الا تخ خافوا ولا تحزنوا الا
تخافوا ولا تحزنوا وابشروا
بالجنه التي كنتم
توعدون نحن
اولياؤكم في الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره
ولكم فيها ما تشتهي انفسكم ولكم فيها ما
تدعون نزلا من غفور رحيم
ومن احسن قولا ممن دعا الى الله وعمل
صالحا وقال انني من
المسلمين ولا تستوي الحسنه ولا السيئه
ادفع بالتي هي احسن ادفع بالتي هي احسن
فاذا الذي بينك وبينه
عداوه كانه ولي حميم
وما يلقاها الا الذين صبروا وما يلقاها
الا ذو حظ
عظيم واما
ينزغنك من
الشيطان فاستعذ
بالله انه هو السميع العليم ومن اياته
الليل والنهار والشمس والقمر لا تسجدوا
للشمس ولا للقمر واسجدوا للذي
خلقهن ان كنتم اياه
تعبدون واسجدوا لله الذي خلقهن ان كنتم
اياه تعبدون فان استكبروا فالذين عند ربك
يسبحون له بالليل والنهار وهم لا
يسمون الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
ومن انك تض خاشعه فاذا انزلنا عليها
الماء اهتزت وربت ان الذي احياها لمحيي
الموتى
انه على كل
شيء ان الذين يلحدون في
اياتنا
علينا افمن يل النار خير ام من ياتي امنا
يوم
القيامه اعملوا ما شئتم انه لا تعملون
بصير ان الذين كفروا بالذكر لما
جاءهم وانه لكتاب عزيز لا ياتيه الباطل من
بين يديه ولا من خلفه
تنزيل من حكيم
حميد ما يقال لك الا ما قد قيل للرسل من
قبلك ان ربك لذو مغفره وذو عقاب اليم ولو
جعلناه قرانا اعجميا لقالوا لولا فصلت
اياته اعجمي
وعربي قل هو للذين امنوا هدى
وشفاء والذين في في قلو قل هو للذين امنوا
هدى
وشفاء والذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره
هو والذين لا يؤمنون في اذانهم وقر وهو
عليهم عما
اولئك ينادون من مكان
بعيد قد اتينا موسى الكتاب فاختلف فيه
ولولا كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي بينهم وانهم
لفي شك منه
مريب من عمل صالحا فلنفسه ومن
اساء
فعليها وما ربك الا من
للعبيد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله صلاه
الوتر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والتين
والزيتون وطور
سينين وهذا البلد
الامين لقد خلقنا
الانسان في احسن
تقويم ثم رددناه اسفل
سين الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فلهم
اجر غير
ممنون فما يكذب بعد
بالدين اليس الله باحكم
الحاكمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
وايا اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم ير المغضوب
الضين
امين انا انزلناه في ليله القدر
وما ادراك ما ليله القدر ليله القدر خير
من الف شهر تنزل
الملائكه والروح فيها باذن ربهم من كل امر
سلام هي حتى مطلع الفجر الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستق الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضال
امين قل الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع
الله لم من
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم لا ذنبا الا غفرته ولا دينا
الا قضيته ولا مريضا الا شفيته ولا ميتا
الا ولا مبتلا الا
عافيته ولا حاجه من حوائج الدنيا والاخره
الا قضيتها ويسرتها يا اكرم
الاكرمين ربنا لا تجعلنا فتنه للقوم
الظالمين ونجنا برحمتك من القوم
الكافرين اللهم انا نسالك التقى والهدى
والعفاف
والغنى اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه في
الدنيا
والاخره اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف
عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم انا نسالك من خير ما سالك منه نبيك
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ونعوذ بك من شر
ما استعاذك منه نبيك محمد صلى صل الله
عليه وسلم اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر واكتب
لنا ثوابها واجعلنا فيها من عتقائك من
النار ومن
المقبولين اللهم اغفر لنا
ولابائنا
وهات ولاصحاب الحقوق علينا واغفر للمؤمنين
والمؤمنات والمسلمين والمسلمات
احياء وامواتا
اللهم انا نسالك من خيري الدنيا والاخره
ونسالك حسن الخاتمه اللهم دبر لنا فانا لا
نحسن التدبير واختر لنا فانا لا نحسن
الاختيار اللهم يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام ويا ذا الفضل
والانعام اللهم من على اخواننا المستضعفين
في كل مكان بالنصر
والتمكين اللهم من على اخواننا في غزه
بالنصر
والتمكين اللهم اهلك عدوهم اللهم اهلك
عدوهم اقتلهم بددا واحصهم عددا ولا تذر
منهم احدا اللهم اقسم الظالمين واقسم
المتجبرين واقسم المستكبرين في الارض بغير
الحق يا رب
العالمين اللهم لا تذهب هذه
الدماء هدرا اللهم لا تذهب هذه الدماء
هدرا اللهم انتقم لعبادك يا رب
العالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا
من
الظالمين ربنا ظلمنا انفسنا ظلما كثيرا
وان لم تغفر لنا وترحمنا لنكونن من
الخاسرين
وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
[Silence]
اجمعين